vogliamo innanzitutto ringraziare gli
organizzatori per averci invitato sul
palco del ted è per noi un grande onore
essere qui
oltre a essere un grande privilegio è
anche una bella responsabilità
dato che in questo momento
rappresentiamo un intero settore quello
dell'agroalimentare che amiamo in modo
particolare dato che abbiamo scelto come
stile di vita anni fa ormai innanzitutto
ci presentiamo lei e micaela classe 89
viola da sempre e platino da qualche
anno la parte più bella di me come vi
piace definirla ma anche la più magra
come si può notare e precisa puntuale
suona il sassofono quando non la sente
nessuno ed è una grande esperta di self
lei angela nata nell 86 vive
praticamente su facebook e dissacra e
nel tempo libero gioca a pallavolo ha
preso una laurea in economia proprio qui
a lecce e in azienda
non abbiamo ancora capito di preciso
cosa fa ma lo fa molto bene a quanto
pare il nostro padre a una macelleria da
30 anni a cisternino vende carne locale
è un bravo artigiano è cresciuto sin da
piccolo come garzone nelle botteghe nel
2000 decide di costruire un'azienda vera
e propria per fare della sua passione un
lavoro un po più strutturato
nasce così quella che sarebbe diventata
la nostra seconda casa
le cose vanno molto bene tanto lavoro
giornate molto intense tanti clienti e
anche qualche sincero rapporto di
amicizia
dopo i primi entusiasmi però le cose
vanno meno bene poi ancora meno poi male
fino a conoscere per la prima volta
adolescenti che sapore anno le parole
tribunale asta giudiziaria procedura
concorsuale liquidatoria allora avevo 19
anni tutta la vita davanti e il sogno di
fare qualcosa nella vita che fosse
l'espressione massima della mia indole
espansiva e colorata io di anni ne avevo
16 il banco di liceo pedagogico davanti
è un sassofono che mi portava altrove
tre pomeriggi a settimana
decidiamo entrambe di restare di lottare
con mamma e papà perché l'azienda in cui
abbiamo creduto con tutte le nostre
forze e tutti i nostri risparmi lacrime
sacrifici
lacrime sacrifici ma anche tanti sorrisi
e levatacce la mattina presto perché c'è
sempre qualcosa da fare
l'odore della carne in quello del pepe
mischiato alle ciambelle di nostra nonna
sempre presente nel 2009 dopo cinque
lunghi anni di lotta senza sosta notti
insonni riusciamo a ripartire con le
nostre forze e con le forze di un'altra
splendida famiglia come la nord nostra
la famiglia caramia che ha scelto
insieme a noi di iniziare un percorso
nuovo e che ringraziamo
ripartiamo da zero ripagando quello che
era già nostro
facciamo enormi sacrifici tuttora le
cose iniziano ad andare bene
puntiamo sulla produzione di salumi di
qualità altissima
non scendiamo a compromessi con nessuno
produciamo solo a mano solo materia
prima eccellente e papà insieme a piero
torno a fare quello che sapeva fare
meglio l'artigiano nostro paese alla
paura in tasca nei due a fatica lo
cominciamo a cambiare immagine aziendale
a puntare in alto a scegliere le fiere
giuste per promuovere il nostro prodotto
e arriva italy e arrivano i ristoratori
stellati a non e arrivano i magazzini
harrod's a londra e noi cresciamo piano
piano sempre di più restando con i piedi
saldati a terra ma gli occhi che
guardano al cielo e io e mia sorella per
tutti diventiamo le santori nei due
belle ragazze che invece di fare le
veline hanno scelto di mischiarsi in un
mondo maschile come quello dei salumi
per provare a cambiarlo un po a renderlo
bello vivace nuovo glamour ma con
sostanza e oggi che stiamo per arrivare
al milione di euro di fatturato e
abbiamo assunto tra i ragazzi
nell'ultimo anno e che tutto il
territorio che ci circonda sta evolvendo
nascono i concorrenti aprono aziende di
packaging oggi che vengono in visita da
noi persone da tutto il mondo per vedere
come si fa un capocollo di martina
franca presidio slow food dal vivo
beh oggi ci sentiamo solo dire grazie a
quella scelto di restare una delle
chiavi fondamentali del nostro lavoro
sicuramente la serietà
sì
vogliamo racchiudere la nostra strada
rivoluzionaria in tre concetti chiave
generazioni noi non abbiamo scelto di
scavalcare la generazione che ci ha
preceduto quella di nostro padre è
quella di piero ma di avere uno scambio
e quindi di farci insegnare la passione
per questo lavoro e di insegnare a loro
un modo diverso di raccontarlo e di
descriverlo di comunicarlo anche
attraverso gli hashtag ai social network
se vuoi andare lontano veloce va da solo
se vuoi andare lontano va insieme e noi
vogliamo andare molto lontano
innovazione meridiana cioè che parte dal
basso dalle radici ed e un po quello che
abbiamo fatto noi prendere il testimone
dai nonni dai nonni dei nostri nonni
quindi la tradizione però presentarla e
raccontarla secondo il nostro stile
abbiamo cercato di unire i concetti di
salumi e di bellezza due concetti che
sicuramente sono in contrapposizione tra
loro ma che unendoli per noi si sono
rilevati vincenti le abbiamo fatto
diventare un concetto unico e oggi per
noi è assolutamente uno stile di vita
come dice michelangelo ogni blocco di
pietra a uno stato dentro di sé ed è
compito dello scultore scoprirla
con questa frase molto bella quello che
vogliamo trasferirvi oggi è che
indipendentemente dal lavoro che ognuno
di noi può svolgere la differenza la
facciamo noi
la fate voi la fanno le persone e siamo
noi che se abbiamo un sogno è una forte
passione possiamo rendere qualsiasi cosa
qualcosa di unico perché in fondo
l'innovazione non è soltanto una grande
innovazione tecnologica come quelle che
abbiamo visto tante storie che abbiamo
sento oggi ma è anche e soprattutto
secondo noi un nuovo modo di raccontare
le cose diverse originali proprio come
uno scultore sa fare e infine amore
questo sentimento per noi per me
racchiude un po tutto
la passione che è quella cosa che ti fa
tenere sempre a fuoco l'obiettivo ti fa
guardare sempre fisso in una direzione e
soprattutto come nel nostro caso quello
di diffondere un concetto di qualità e
di eccellenza da un'altra parte però la
passione ti aiuta a stimolare sempre di
più la curiosità a cercare di andare
oltre i propri limiti migliorarsi
continuamente che la cosa fondamentale è
un'altra cosa importante è il cuore
senza il quale sicuramente oggi non
saremmo qui perché amare ciò che ci
rende davvero invincibili vorremmo
vorremmo concludere dicendo che secondo
noi la rivoluzione sta tutta in un solo
semplicissimo concetto la fiducia in noi
stesse nelle persone che fanno questo
percorso con me ogni giorno nel
territorio in cui viviamo e chi per
primo ha messo in campo la fiducia
chi ha dato fiducia noi per prime e
quindi è stato il più rivoluzionario di
tutti è il nostro padre giuseppe che non
lo sa ma invitiamo a salire qui sul
palco perché se lo merita più di tutti
noi
non devi dire niente grazie